[Musica]
nella vita di ogni giorno e sul lavoro è
molto facile complicare le cose molto
difficile è semplificarle noi esseri
umani amiamo la complessità e anche
quando non lo amiamo la produciamo siamo
orientati alle entropia talvolta alla
confusione seguiamo insomma le grandi
leggi diciamo della fisica no un po
tutti noi per dargli una dimostrazione
finale di questa tesi potrei farvi
vedere ad esempio l'armadio delle mie
figlie ovviamente questa è un'immagine
di repertorio perché ci tengo a
sopravvivere a questo ted nella vita mi
occupo di tecnologia in particolare di
intelligenza artificiale un mondo che
già di per se stesso riporta la mente
un'idea di grande complessità ed in
effetti è un mondo particolarmente
complesso è particolarmente ampio
parliamo di tecniche di metodologie di
ambiti applicativi estremamente diversi
che vanno dall'analisi delle immagini
all'automazione dei processi produttivi
che arrivano alla guida autonoma gli
algoritmi predittivi
all'interno di questo vastissimo mondo
un ambito che mi ha sempre
particolarmente affascinato e quello del
linguaggio naturale
dell'interpretazione del più naturale
dei nostri strumenti che proprio il
parlato chiaramente all'interno di
questo mondo il linguaggio naturale e le
tecniche di sviluppo del network
language processing sono fra le più
complesse perché il nostro modo di
comunicare è un costrutto non solo
linguistico ma un costrutto sociale ed
emotivo pensate che gli algoritmi che si
usano oggi nel mondo
dell'interpretazione del linguaggio sono
algoritmi che gestiscono miliardi di
parametri contemporaneamente miliardi di
parametri e che dunque vanno ad
interpretare appunto come noi
comunichiamo
l'idea di lavorare sul mondo del network
language processing è partita per me
parecchi anni fa io mi occupavo di
sistemi di gestione dei clienti
all'interno delle grandi organizzazioni
questi sistemi erano nati diversi anni
fa con un intento diciamo molto utile
capire perché i clienti stavano
contattando le grandi organizzazioni le
grandi aziende e permettere di mappare
queste interazioni per appunto attivare
una serie di processi chiaramente con
l'evoluzione dei prodotti dei servizi
che queste aziende e fornivano questi
sistemi sono diventati dei veri e propri
mostri di complessità mostri di
complessità difficilissimi da alimentare
per coloro che li dovevano gestire e
anche difficilissimi da interpretare per
chi da questi sistemi doveva trarre
delle informazioni utili all'evoluzione
del business e dell'offerta e da lì e mi
è venuta sostanzialmente l'idea ma
perché non tornare al parlato a capire
che cosa ci stiano effettivamente
dicendo i clienti che cosa ci stiano
comunicando cosa stiano lamentando a
quali informazioni siano realmente
interessati ed è scoccata diciamola la
freccia di cupido nei confronti
dell'intelligenza artificiale il natural
language processing chiaramente apre la
sponda ad una molteplicità di
riflessione differenti e questo anche
tutto il vasto mondo dell'intelligenza
artificiale che poc'anzi vi accennavo
chiaramente su un mondo tanto vasto
tanto complesso tanto impattante sulla
vita di tutti noi e con tante
prospettive e future si potrebbero
innestare una molteplicità di
ragionamenti differenti che forse ci
porterebbero anche a considerazioni ed
attesi fra di loro differenti e talvolta
anche confliggenti ma uno degli aspetti
sicuramente più affascinanti di tutto
questo di tutta questa evoluzione
tecnologica riguarda la semplicità che
questo tipo di tecnologie possono
introdurre per noi siamo tutti abituati
nella nostra vita quotidiana ad
utilizzare smartphone e device di vario
tipo con grande facilità per funzioni e
di base estremamente semplici come la
ricerca della musica o del meteo di un
po di un percorso ma pensate che cosa
tutto questo potrebbe portare se
riuscissimo ad introdurre questi
paradigmi di semplicità all'interno di
mondi altamente complessi mondi che
impattano la vita quotidiana di tutti
noi in maniere molto differenti il
concetto di semplicità non è senz'altro
un concetto nuovo
sia un concetto che ha accompagnato nel
corso della storia l'innovazione
tecnologica ed ha sempre guidato il
pensiero di grandi scienziati ed
innovatori ma perché secondo me oggi
questo concetto assume un significato
particolare sul quale riflettere e fare
delle riflessioni in una logica di
trasforma perché semplicità è una parola
in se stessa racchiude tutta una serie
di benefici collaterali impliciti
semplicità significa velocità rapida
esecuzione dei task risparmio di tempo
durante la nostra giornata
ma significa che se all'interno delle
grandi organizzazioni
risparmio di risorse risparmio di
energia significa poi trasparenza perché
la semplicità è comprensibile a tutti e
immediatamente accessibile e significa
da ultimo anche inclusione chiunque può
accedere con minori barriere barriere
che talvolta e la tecnologia stessa
porre ai servizi ai prodotti ea ciò di
cui ha bisogno
certamente di ceva charlie chaplin da
semplicità non è una cosa semplice è a
mio parere aveva perfettamente ragione
perché perché qui parliamo di applicare
questi nuovi paradigmi tecnologici a
mondi che per loro natura sono altamente
stratificati e complessi pensiamo alla
pubblica amministrazione ai suoi
processi
o pensiamo ad esempio alla sanità
quindi stiamo parlando di analizzare e
trasformare mondi complessi mondi che
hanno una stratificazione normativa una
stratificazione di processo una
stratificazione culturale mondi che sono
impattati da una molteplicità anche di
aspetti etici e di combinare questi
mondi con la grande complessità
dell'intelligenza artificiale
io credo che dalla somma di queste due
cose possa nascere un risultato buono un
risultato che va nella direzione della
semplicità la parola dicevamo far
parlare i dati non soltanto nel senso di
correlarli tra di loro di trovare nuove
chiavi di lettura nuove opportunità
nuovi modelli di business da poter
portare avanti ma anche nel senso
letterale del termine renderli
accessibili
tutti in maniera facile non solamente a
coloro che hanno il background tecnico
per accedere ma tutti noi
ecco pensiamo ad esempio ad un contesto
diciamo complesso come può essere quello
della sanità la sanità è un contesto nel
quale tutti noi ci siamo ritrovati in
attesa di una diagnosi all'interno di
qualche ospedale magari con uno stato un
po ansioso per capire un sintomo o per
ispezionare una situazione che stiamo
vivendo di qualche tipo
l'architetto mario cucinella che è un
architetto molto noto molto famoso per
la sua visione orientata alla
sostenibilità e all'umanizzazione dei
luoghi dice che il miglior ospedale sarà
quello di cui sempre meno persone
avranno bisogno
ecco dietro questa idea dietro questo
nuovo paradigma c'è molto
dell'intelligenza artificiale c'è l'idea
di mettere il medico nelle condizioni di
disporre delle informazioni e dei dati
sintetici in tempo reale relativamente
al decorso di un proprio paziente c'è
anche l'idea di poter ascoltare
realmente il paziente senza doversi
preoccupare di tutte le procedure di
tutti gli orpelli che derivano dai
sistemi informativi ma pensiamo ancora
alla burocrazia che ci circonda il tema
della burocrazia evidentemente non è
solo un ostacolo per noi cittadini
quando vogliamo accedere a dei servizi
in maniera semplice o compilare dei form
o comprendere certe procedure o
normative ma anche un aggravio per tutti
coloro che all'interno di questo mondo
lavorano questa persona stanca sui
faldoni è abbastanza rappresentativa
della complessità della stratificazione
che caratterizza molti di questi mondi
oggi grazie a queste nuove tecnologie
possibile ripensare all'approccio di
accesso alle informazioni
ripensare all'approccio di accesso ai
dati e pensarlo in una maniera semplice
che sia accessibile a tutti
indipendentemente dal background tecnico
che le persone abbiano pensate agli open
data a quei dati pubblici che le
pubbliche amministrazioni possono
mettere a disposizione di tutti per
creare nuovi modelli di business
quanto sarebbe utile a molti di voi
poter accedere questi dati in maniera
facile con le pagina turale per avere
nuove idee per pensare a nuovi percorsi
ma pensiamo a molti altri mondi diciamo
tipici del nostro tessuto territoriale e
della nostra attività produttiva come ad
esempio il turismo correlare i beni
culturali poterli navigare e ricercare
in maniera facile costruire percorsi
costruire logiche che corte che
colleghino tutto questo le nostre
passioni i nostri interessi poter
valutare e comprendere a fondo quale sia
la migliore esperienza da proporre ai
visitatori ai viaggiatori che vengono
sul nostro territorio cosa piace e cosa
interessa di meno
ripensare i modelli di smart cities le
nostre città la loro vivibilità i
trasporti e trasporti intelligenti tutto
questo paradigma di semplicità sarà alla
nostra portata lavorando sul tema
dell'intelligenza artificiale in
connessione con tutte le variabili di
contesto
in questo senso ho provato riflettere su
quali possano essere alcuni principi
guida fra i vari che possono aiutarci
nel disegno e di un percorso di
semplificazione del mondo che ci
circonda e ne ho ricondotti
fondamentalmente tre fa i vari che mi
sembrano particolarmente
significativi il primo è la visione
visione significa chiaramente
immaginazione significa vedere qualcosa
che non è di immediata lettura per
pensare ad un percorso migliore appunto
di accesso alle cose che ci servono ma
visione significa anche capire queste
cose all'interno del contesto in cui
esse vad vanno attuate chiaramente
quando pensiamo alla visione alla
creazione e immaginifica di cose nuove
collegata alla tecnologia ci viene
subito in mente il genio di leonardo e
lui proprio diceva alla semplicità è
l'estrema sofisticazione proprio come
idea fondante su cui bari centrare un
nostro percorso chiaramente nella figura
del genio di leonardo si racchiudono
tutti questi componenti in una mente
sola la capacità di leggere il contesto
la comprensione del potenziale delle
tecniche e della tecnologia ma quando
tutto questo non è nella mente di un
singolo genio io credo che l'idea di
visione sia baricentrata su una
multidisciplinarietà
quindi sulla nostra capacità di mettere
a fattor comune competenze chiave di
lettura e differenti per arrivare a un
risultato che sia veramente
significativo per il benessere
collettivo
il secondo principio è quello
dell'utilità chiaramente l'innovazione
tecnologica non soltanto l'intelligenza
artificiale deve portare un beneficio
che sia tangibile e che lo sia per una
collettività di individui la più vasta
possibile
ci sono alcune innovazioni la cui
utilità è immediatamente leggibile
quando vediamo ad esempio un trolley il
bello della semplicità e che la
semplicità non serve spiegarla non c'è
bisogno di manualistica per capire a
cosa serve un trolley e il beneficio che
si possa portare nei nostri spostamenti
ci sono poi invece altri casi in cui
diciamo l'esercizio è un po più ostico è
però qui francamente è l'unico che a mio
parere farebbe un commento utile e
cabile perché oggettivamente e risulta
un pochino più difficile il terzo
principio al principio della certezza
quando parliamo di portare nuovi
paradigmi tecnologici all'interno di
contesti complessi ad alto impatto sulle
nostre vite evidentemente è fondamentale
che l'eliminazione delle ridondanze
quello che guglielmo di ockham appunto e
ci proponeva ci suggeriva in termini di
semplificazione utile di ottimizzazione
delle risorse arrivi del significato e
lo faccia senza creare e disequilibri
nell'esecuzione di ciò che viene
trasformato
evidentemente parlare di inter
artificiale e collegare questo contenuto
alla certezza spiega fare una
moltitudine di riflessioni anche molto
complesse si parla di ex plen ability di
capire perché le macchine per vengano a
certi risultati piuttosto che ad altri
si parla di farne se dunque di come
addestriamo l'intelligenza artificiale e
dunque
per non creare un pregiudizio nei
confronti di soggetti o di classi
differenti si parla ancora di account
ability e di responsabilità quindi di
introdurre trasformazione innovazione e
semplificazione ma senza per perdere il
controllo il governo loughner ship la
responsabilità e sui processi che
trasformiamo dunque visione utilità
certezza questo
lutto per correre con voi e ci riporta a
quello che per me è il più alto
significato della tecnologia mettere la
persona al centro portare un'innovazione
che genere di un beneficio tangibile per
ciascuno di noi
steve jobs diceva che bisogna lavorare
molto duro per semplificare il proprio
pensiero ma che quando si raggiunge
questo grado di semplificazione si
saranno spostate le montagne
ecco oggi la nostra montagna è fatta di
di dati e di servizi complessi di
burocrazia e dunque io penso che se
avremo la volontà se riusciremo a
lavorare in maniera interdisciplinare su
tutte queste tematiche se riuscirei
realmente a dare una visione al nostro
percorso che sia utile è certa per la
comunità non soltanto avremo spostato
quella montagna ma avremmo creato tante
opportunità nuove opportunità per
ciascuno di noi grazie
[Applauso]